welcome everyone we're gonna start the
lecture tonight on a Mila game and I
picked the the first game to game over
or to start with is the game deep blue
computer versus Kasparov and then there
were a couple of other examples so we're
not going to spend too much time on the
opening and now I want to get to the
middle game from where I want you to try
to find the best moves in the middle
game and and I will help you of course
so II 45 so we have the which opening is
this yes Lopez
so a rope Louie Lopez opening we have
spyro is playing with the black pieces
this game was played in 1997 back then
computers were not as strong as right
now last I think almost last 10 years
they no longer have this matches because
it just computers are too strong right
now to play against the human so that's
why before it was really big I mean
Kramnik played a match
Kasparov had couple of matches and it
was really big and a really big prize
funds in this matches you know players
would earn like around million dollars
playing these computers but nowadays I
guess no one really wants to put money
on this events because they just
machines are just too strong right now
the play recently there was a the match
between Komodo engine and Hikaru
Nakamura where engine was giving him
couple of moves you know odds so Ricardo
had couple of extra moves in one game he
was happy exchange in one game he was up
upon and even with the odds he still
lost the match three draws in a win for
Komodo and several other top
grandmasters try to defeat it and again
no success
even with those odds right now just you
know it's very difficult for the humans
to to defeat the machine so that shows
how strong they the you know the engines
are nowadays so ok so let's get to the
crucial moment so ok sort of theory this
is very standard the knight transfer on
g3 white is a little bit better but
black is also very solid seer now d5 the
first move engine goes d5 deep blue it's
a good move in my opinion because it's
gaining space and also entering to the
blacks territory first first four ranks
is 4y the other four is four blocks so
pawn on d5 is already entering to this
territory and
gaining what that is very important yes
gaining a temple excellent
besides the temple for a long term what
does he have for a long term space right
he is gaining space advantage 97 Bishop
III you know you could tell by just
looking at the position that white is
already slightly better because he has
space advantage thanks to the d5 pawn
his pieces have a little bit more room
but black is very solid no weaknesses so
engine goes going to and here Knight h7
basically what 90-87 it's unclear what
black really trying to do with this move
perhaps it was better to just play Queen
c8 here and just just continue with
Queen b7 rookie b8 just just to stay put
so Kasparov tried night h7 here and a
for what white is going to try to do
here he's going to try to open up the a
file and gain a file to try to have some
advantage so this is the start where
basically computer starts to improve his
position to have some advantage so he
starts out with a four night h4 night
each for Queen h4 some liquidations and
now Queen e2 putting some pressure on b5
and also creating a threat of Bishop d3
that is coming up to put some pressure
on b5 now he has to go back because he
doesn't have another way to protect it
be 5 so Queen also on h4 not doing
anything there is no prospects to attack
now see he had to go back now this is
the problem
Kasparov lost some temples and now
before putting pressure on c5 Queen c7
rook ec1 at some point white maybe even
trying to play c4 here to x-ray the
Queen
so you will see four and now position is
getting close and now this is the
position I want you to think try to
spend a little bit of time and find the
good plan here constructive plan here
for white to try to get the control how
can he try to get the control of the
open file huh
how can he try to get the control of
that open file let's think about it
how can he achieve that huh achieve that
control long-term plan for the engine
here so he can try to put pressure yes
it's absolutely that's what he's trying
to do first he's going to line up the
rooks and if he needs some more power
then he will bring the Queen et to give
as well absolutely rook a tree and rook
here coming here okay now there's some
problems with a B a B rook a7 so he goes
to move Queen d8 just trying to defend
and now a stunning move stunning move
because you may think that white is just
going to concentrate now playing on a
queen side right but that's what engines
are you know very strong it at any given
moment they could have another
unexpected idea from this other side of
the board and that's what he did exactly
here yes yes f4 exclamation mark now
he's playing on both sides of the board
that's a you know strength of a very
strong player that is not too focused on
one side of the board and he's trying to
create counter play from the other side
as well
so f4 is coming to put some serious
pressure okay to put some very serious
pressure only five now he goes here
Knight f6
F takes e5 f takes e5 and now he play
the move Queen f1 Knight goes back on d6
that's what he's trying to do Kasparov
now Queen f2 perhaps here engine should
play Queen f2 immediately but the
position is closed and black doesn't
help that much now many other different
plans so that's why even wasting a tempo
is not that crucial Bishop b6 cleany 8
now he just sits rookie 3a - in some
point he's going to take on a file
you're just waiting for the right moment
black cannot do anything this is the
worst thing for a player to be in a
position where you have no active plan
you just have to wait sit sit to see how
opponent is improving the position
Bishop e7 Bishop c5 activating the dark
square bishop see he's just sitting
nothing else he can do
and now Knight f5 comes in now he is
activating the Knight Bishop takes f5
the problem taking back with the knight
is after it takes F this Bishop is going
to sit only for here and there isn't d6
ideas so it's going to be a lot of
pressure
yeah Bishop takes f5 pawn takes f5 f6
this is the only way to prevent black
from playing f6 himself to break through
and open the position so that's the idea
to prevent f6 and now difficult decision
difficult decision but let's see if you
can find it spend couple of minutes here
and try to find the best idea here for
white you need to find a way to break
through but
how you have the pair of the bishops
while we know that sometimes in a closed
positions nights are more effective than
the bishops right so never be too
attached to your pieces because
sometimes even the piece that looks good
maybe needs to be exchanged for example
okay so it's very important that you
don't get attached okay to your pieces
too much okay all right
anybody else let's see okay we have two
people let's give a little bit more time
because it's a crucial moment one
inaccurate decision and you might lose
most of your advantage here so that's
why you have to think here you cannot
just say one move and if you're going to
say the answer please I have a plan not
just a move okay I need a constructive
plan here not just a move
now because you know black black was
maybe trying to play efore at some point
to get some activities yes what's the
what's the move here Bishop takes d6
correct we should take the six and now
which move technically speaking you can
do that but how about we blockade that
pawn first so we don't have to worry
about it okay how about we blow kid that
is that a possibility yeah so we just
stop the contra play first right
he took took and put the Bishop only
four okay that way now he will have the
a file now and he will have a strong
Bishop only four takes and look at that
who has the a file now whiteheads and
blackheads absolutely no counterplay in
this position and now white is going to
try to activate his pieces Queen d7 by
Kasparov and now where do we go
Queen a7 initiate the exchange because
bees b5 pawn is going to be weak rock c7
Queen b6 getting ready now to activate
the rook Queen b7 check queen eight six
it's amazing
you will see in some point now computer
is going to make a mistake and the
current computers would never make a
mistake like this current computers will
show here in white is already winning
plus 5 or plus 4 but you'll see he makes
a mistake and you have a question queen
watch sorry
yeah well if you trade Queens you're
going to drop that b5 on eventually so
that's why if let's say you take right I
take so the problem is your life scores
are very weak too so you you have
absolutely no counter play now and I
even have ideas of getting the king in
here so the problem is you're just going
to be very passive okay so that's why he
didn't want to do that so he went here
check rookies in Queen eight six is
correct Queen c7
now you go screen here threating mate on
e8 win b6 check in here and now he makes
a move that allows the Contra play
question mark
it's it's amazing you know this this is
a very famous game here computer now
made a mistake okay
computer computer made a mistake in this
position okay computer made a mistake
and Kasparov actually resigned two moves
later missing a chance to draw the game
so it's very interesting he missed the
chance to draw okay so let's see now
it's your turn now what do you think is
the best move here what do you think is
the best move here to try to hold try to
win this position for white first let's
try to figure out the best way to play
here the queen is changing you have
couple of options move the King exchange
the Queen so you have to figure out what
you're going to do now well I said that
was the hard part and even engine made a
mistake yeah it's unbelievable yeah that
a computer made a mistake you know at
that time this was almost 20 years ago
actually 19 years ago so the engines
were just starting out so those so they
weren't us yes
which will that's what that's what the
engine played the correct move here
actually is King h1
okay because now if the Queens exchange
occurred then c6 pawn is very strong why
should be able to win this if rook b8
just simply Roque 6 and black can try to
activate but here just simply take and
our route goes back protecting the
background now check and checkmate on g7
cannot cannot be stopped okay it just
simply cannot be stopped if there is a
check only one I just go King h2o so you
just can position cannot be protected
all right so that's why he should have a
king h1 computer when King f1 and now
Luke p8 was played and it's amazing
after okay six cuz part of resigned
thinking okay I have to exchange Queens
and okay this is absolutely correct it's
just hopeless because okay someone is
coming Bishop is coming here here c7
King was coming it's a problem okay
that's a real problem here and Queen
Queen takes c6 it's a real problem
but what move did he miss here he
probably didn't miss the move he just
thought there's just nothing so but what
he should have done here before
resigning he should have gone for it
anyway here what do you think
when you're losing you should you should
have a resigner
or if you just try to make the most
active move anyway because maybe there
will be some kind of prep Etios or
something so what is the move here the
most active move here for Kasparov that
he should have done even if he loses
it's fine yes correct so he should have
played the move Queen III right you
probably saw that Queen takes d6 losing
the bishop and he thought okay if I give
a check he just goes here you probably
just looked at the check he goes here
and check basically the king will slowly
run out you know here perhaps something
like this but but instead here he could
have played the move Queen d6 rook e8
very powerful move and now he's
threatening to win the bishop and if
Bishop f3 check King f2 and apparently
here there is no way to avoid the
perpetual unbelievable because he just
there is no way to avoid it
okay so Bishop e1 check check
check again check again check check this
way huh because if it goes here you need
to have a check here see don't don't
check from here because if you check
from here then he hides you don't have
any more checks so you have to know from
where to check so Quinn is a once again
we see Quinn is a very tricky piece and
always have this chances to do a
perpetual okay so never never resigned
too early plan till the very end because
you never know there might be a
possibility for you your question you
could but the problem the problem is now
your king is very exposed you're not
meeting me right now
if you were maybe yeah but you're not
meeting me here check I go here the
problem is you're not meeting me here
okay if you were meeting me yeah we
could but there is no meet here you're
going to go here yeah you're going to
try to meet me on here on here but the
problem is I'm going to be in time to
give you the perpetual check check check
check so amazing yeah computer makes a
mistake allows Kasparov to come back and
then he just missed that he perhaps
could have still a draw drawn with the
Queen III move here this is a very
important idea okay just queen is again
once again we see Queen is a very strong
piece and by itself she can try to just
give a lot of checks and force a drop
okay I have one more example for you
about the open file I won't show you
this position and see if you can find a
correct plan this is the game played by
Capablanca okay this is played in 1929
capablanca three ball game and it's
white to play and find a way to win to
break through here okay as you can see
position is very close they haven't even
exchanged one pawn
in fact they've only exchanged two minor
pieces each a bishop and a knight so but
let's think of a plan okay
what kind of plan you have here to try
to win this game
yeah managed to win this very nicely in
fact if you don't have this one
particular plan that I think your
position looks great but you're not
going to be able to win this game okay
so it looks great but you are not going
to be able to break through why to move
correct
why to play and night for me to find a
winning plan here one suggestion for you
is when you see a locked and closed
position like this always think about
the breakthroughs okay
think about what you're going to do to
make a breakthrough okay look for a
potential breakthroughs okay so that's
something to remember okay
aha
correct yes that's what kappa blanka did
because you know you even if you lose
the pawn you go to be one excellent you
will take it there's no way he will be
able to hang on to the path so the
correct move here is b5 the reason you
want to keep this here because you're
putting pressure and that's going to
make it difficult for him to switch back
to defense so now he takes your pawn
okay and now very important the
intermediate move you need to play here
very very important intermediate move
you need to play because if you take you
know it's also going to be probably okay
for you but this move is very important
because that way you going to push his
pieces to the background and they going
to be just blocking each other so what
can you do here first yes
Bravo correct h6 check this is called
intermediate check okay intermediate
check before capturing in between check
now he has to go here and only then you
take because now if it takes par this
way what do you have here
c6 correct discovery check discovery
check and winning the bishop
so he played King g7 what do you play
now now this is important moment here
because it's you have a good position
but he's ready to go okay it he's ready
to go okay and kind of kick your queen
away and try to hold it so this
particular move is very important to
play here not a very natural move
actually not a very natural move to play
here yes yes okay one is possible okay
one is definitely a possibility but then
he will play something like rook b8 Ruby
the rook c8 and then Queen d8 and he
will stay put at least I'm going to stop
that I don't want his look to get to the
bb-8 eh yes correct
p6 locking the position but now you can
have this outpost on the seventh rank b6
excellent job Queen b8 and now this
rooks no longer have anything to do here
right so they're going to come where
open file remember rooks belong on open
file so remember that rook a one rook c8
Queen before rook h d8
rook a7 King f8 and now this rook needs
to be back
rook h1 look how capablanca is
maneuvering his pieces now he controls
the a file as well
King g8 rook one to a fourth King f8
rook to a3
I'm sorry Queen to a tree and now
it's a battery I hear he is setting up
and now basically he needs to find a
plan he he went back and forth a little
bit he played King g3 Bishop d7 King
gauge for I don't really why I think he
was just trying to make the time control
or something that's what it looks like
at least king h4 King g3 Bishop d7 King
H working h8 now Queen a1 King goes back
to g8 King g3 King f8 okay so they reach
this position after some shuffling
sometimes players they just make this
moves to make the time control for
example and now the plan what is the
plan here
he could have made this earlier but you
just need to find this particular plumb
here and you will be winning the game
and think a little bit it's not so
obvious this plum okay but this is your
winning plan and he saw this he were
just just shuffling around this piece is
a little bit there and you'll see why he
put the king here it was very important
to King to be here otherwise there could
have been some tactical ideas tactical
shots like 95 so here is simply trying
to avoid those Bravo
you found the winning plan yes this is
the winning plan everyone and this is
the target night will arrive to a5 and
black is not going to be able to defend
against this so he simply went 90 to
Bishop d7 night sorry Knight b3 is
trying to regroup so he at least can try
to defend somehow with 98 but for a
moment it looks like he managed to do
that yeah he managed to successfully
defend but it only looks like because
now you have a very strong move here
let's see who will see this move very
powerful move and now position is going
to collapse you just have too much space
advantage here look at this this pawn is
very strong this pawn too much space he
can barely move his pieces the old
shuffled back on a background because
he's got no space and you have a space
advantage okay so let's see now how are
we gonna do it okay think don't rush
don't rush try to see the good move
this was a very important move for this
position you need to realize that there
is a piece now for black that is hanging
okay
there is a piece right now for black is
hanging and you might be able to do some
kind of tactical idea to take advantage
of it okay to take advantage of it ha ha
okay well okay you night to be said
that's what you're suggesting - mm
that's a good move but what about the
better one huh what about a better one
who has a better one no no no waiting
don't guess now don't guess now remember
the rules in when you see a good move
look for a better one who has the better
move here
no looking a quintic see correct answer
that's what you did that's wood kappa
blanka did world champion number three
right Bishop a6 very powerful move now
black cannot defend this pawn and if it
captures d7 Bishop is hanging along with
h7 punishing your rook is going to be
very powerful here so he had to take no
choice now you take here now treating to
take this he goes rookie seven and now
finishing touch the finishing touch here
let's see who can find it quickly though
so this one you have to find quickly
raise your hand if you have this one yes
correct answer Bravo rook takes da check
eliminating the guard deflecting the
defenders and then ninety six is a
really very pretty fork here and then
you also take the a6 pawn and you're
completely winning all right okay very
good
another middle game position we saw
how to break through okay closed
position how to break through it's very
very important to remember okay I would
like to do one more position okay and so
you can see how to play in a position
like this so in this position white has
a very minimal advantage and this is a
position play by a grandmaster after you
support and very minimal advantage here
we see four white okay let's think about
it this is a Yusupov game from 1988
against I'm not sure the title of his
opponent but so look at the position it
looks like black is doing not that bad
right I mean six pounds each let's spend
a couple of minutes to try to evaluate
the position first of all what is the
evaluation of this position white well
it's very important whose turn is it
because if it's black to move black will
play rook da tenth there is nothing
white you know why it doesn't have
anything so it's all about this team
we're working on today it's open file
okay so open file how to take advantage
of it in the middle game and also this
last example is an endgame position so
okay so who can tell me the evaluation
of this position meaning who is better
and give me some reasons why yes white
is slightly better right why you can
over the T file okay doesn't block to
move then it's equal yeah yeah equal but
there's one more thing I like you to
mention about the position besides the
file there is something that white has
the black doesn't have sometimes - ever
when you need to figure out who is
better you look at the pawn structures
okay so let's look at the pawn structure
here look at
white structure and black structure what
is the difference in the structure
uh-huh that's what I wanted to hear okay
is that what you were trying to say okay
good so why it has queenside majority
what is majority everyone everyone
understand what is majority in this kind
of positions when you have extra pawn on
one side of the board black has a king
size majority but usually King side
majority it's very rarely you can do
anything with this okay but Queens and
majority it's very direct I can just go
be for c5 then I have a passed pawn I
have the majority okay so but it's not
about the majority right now what is the
most important thing white should do
here rook to d1 of course control the
file that's what he did
queen d3 g6 black is okay a very solid
still right you don't have a way to make
progress here unless you play this
particular move this move is very
important for you to play because his
queen is very annoying any time he's
going to jump in here and start
attacking so his queen is actually a
very good piece here it's a piece that
you want to sort of eliminate it's a
very strong piece here the Queen so what
are we going to do to eliminate this
Queen here Queen to d7 interesting
suggestion but that move allows Queen 83
unfortunately now we have to do some
defensive work so what else we can do
that's prevents that correct correct
decision Queen d6 rook e8 lock plays now
Queen d7 because you can no longer go
Queen here because they eat is hanging
so he goes King f8 dubious move by the
way and now he he was trying to exchange
the Queen's but now since black played a
little bit dubious with the skiing
rookie a King f8 he changed his mind and
now he's going to keep the Queen and is
going to try
to get in with rook to the seventh rank
thanks to this particular move here that
he has yes
mmm Queenie for King GA he will go back
so that's why it's not going to do that
much
absolutely Queenie for correct yes
because he can no longer go to Kitty
because after the exchange you're going
to pick up this pawn and now what is
your trade here
rook on a seventh right everybody should
remember rooks belong in India where on
a seventh rank
that's just like a rule so remember that
rooks belong on a seventh rank okay yes
now Queen a4 so he played a five what
else you can try to do correct and now
everybody rook belongs where on the
seventh there you go Nagas Queen c5 in
says you know I'm not going to just give
up that easily
some rookie seven ideas he wants to do
and now black Queen has been active here
okay got kind of activity here when
opponent has an active piece what do we
do trade it yes who can find a good
trade here for white good trade that
will help him to win this game
good trade good trade here Queen is
actively placed yes excellent wolf very
good job yes Queen b5 exchanging the
Queen's and now he took and now this b6
pawn is very weak Brooke wants to go
behind it okay and win the pawn simply
so he played rook c8 trying to get
active the passive defense is not going
to be successful because after a four
let's say black is just sitting here
right you just you just simply bring the
King in if it's just it
okay goes here you go here passive
defense never works in the rookin game
remember that okay almost never works it
breaks through you're still sitting it
breaks through and then he will just
push this pawn and click okay
so remember when the rookin game you
never want to play passively that's what
also player with the black pieces trying
to do he tried to get active with rook
c8 you know he tried to go here but the
problem for him is he's just going to
lose two pounds I mean he's just gonna
be able to black-white is going to have
to connected passed pawns basically
that's what's going to happen here so he
if he goes down here white plays a for
rugby to just picks up this guy then he
comes here picks up this guy and two
connected passed pawns usually decide
the outcome of this game so he tried to
get you know this a foreign you get some
activity but then simply capture look to
see for capture and what is the winning
move huge for white what is the winning
move yes absolutely okay six forcing
offering the exchange of the rooks in
that particular case now this pawn
cannot be stopped
okay so I need that exchanged didn't
occur so let me show you how to win this
kind of position so yeah you know when
you have two connected passed pawns you
just have to push them but you have to
do it push them that way so you don't
lose any of them okay
so you push he's sitting you push right
now you go one square up you push II I
don't know what he does this you just go
up here you don't want any pawn wages
you know or something like that here so
it's it's you push and you Quinn okay
two pounds cannot be stopped with the
rook unless you know if even if his King
comes closer he still cannot stop it so
it's it's it's just a trivial trivial
win if you play it okay very good
questions
anybody has questions you see initial
position they unlock anything that
especially now you may even think that
grandmasters may agree to draw here
because it just kind of looks dry now
but no it's just you know you slowly
slowly improve the position and then you
can have a comfortable position so
that's what you want to try to do never
agree to a draw if you have the open
file to use it and improve your position
so even in a small advantage in
positions you you play until the end and
try to find plants where you can try to
improve your position to the maximum
where all your piece is going to be
active one more thing here I want to
show you if gives you a check here you
go back to before never block the pond
okay never block the past pond he goes
here king c5 now he sits and now you
push usually your past pawn reaches the
sixth rank that's game over okay and
I'll a passed pawn on a6 is just too too
much for him he could have tried to get
active this way but now you win because
of the famous you know building the
breach idea right you simply get here
first of all you get here I'm sorry he
goes here and now well actually yeah you
only need I just go here if black tries
to go here then you start collecting
several pounds and winning the game
okay all right very good so we looked at
a couple of games by two world champions
cuz first game was a deep blue versus
Kasparov where engine made a mistake and
as part of resigned in a position that
was drawn and second one we saw at the
kappa blanka team and then we showed a
Yusupov game where it looked like
absolutely composition but he managed to
slowly slowly improve the positional win
it really the initial position it
doesn't look that better awful black it
looks like he played solidly I mean he
against a strong Grandmaster equalize
but slowly white improves and again the
main reason is because he can get the
control of the open
file okay so the topic of today's
lecture was on open files in all the
games we saw that how important was to
have the open file in the first game
where computer had the a file in the
second example where Capablanca had the
a file and the third example today were
usable Grandmaster Yusupov had the D
file okay okay thank you for everyone
for attending this class and look
forward seeing you on Thursday